the element of Zuke's van in both ponen
beings and items which are very similar
this is kind of a cute position and this
is a win for white believe it or not
even though he has no pawns left and
black is quite advanced with this pawn
and you think that at the very least
he'll be able to stay late himself
however he doesn't succeed in that so if
it's white white on the movies just
wants to maneuver itself to a mating
position so you'll go like here here
King f1 at the right time when the king
is here and the opponent's here is gonna
be made however this is black to move
and still he can't save himself so black
is gonna try to play the move king h1 we
will notice that if instead I'm sorry
it doesn't deal with g5 but it's the
same it is the same idea after g5 of kh1
it's exactly the same thing as you will
see so we can see it g5 9 of six g4 he's
willing to give everything away just to
create a stalemate situation however
after one Fontes taken here King f1 here
mate so g5 doesn't work but also he h1
doesn't work again 9 f6 and now let's
examine the possibilities g5 we already
saw basically we can see it again after
here is the same principle here he's
gonna move the knight and when the pawn
comes to g4 you can imagine I have one
the only bigger move his g3 and night
thanks g3 is made so after King h1
Knight of 6
he's gonna try it again let's try this
here here here here same situation
and lastly after he here he is forcing
him to play h2 and again the same
maneuver 93g for ya and made so this is
the point is that sometimes when there's
issues in space and Zhuge van
there is just no hope for the side to
this cramp okay this is just a warm-up
now to our topic which is mostly
incorrect liquidation into what they
think is a win in actuality it's not
only in this position it's very easy to
see that white is usually better he has
a much better minor piece a much more
active Rock a better pawn structure
right now because those pawns are
falling and even the King is better
placed because this King is a bit
suspicious in g6 with a bishop from g7
so there was a chance to beat Smith
Lahore is not easy to beat and in this
position there really are a lot of good
moves
you can definitely take the pawn there's
nothing wrong with that if you want to
be really prudent you can play King e1
or pe2 just to prevent any penetrations
with the rock like rough check I'm
looking here although in this specific
position it's really not very relevant
but if you really want to do it the the
methodical way move the King there's
just some things are chronic for example
the weakness of the bishop against the
night you cannot fix its forever
therefore the element of time loses a
little bit of its strength so white
plays this move
hitting in itself not a necessity but
again since time is not a big factor
it's not a huge terrible mistake
black brigs the pin what else and in
this position it was not too late to
just admit that the plan was wrong go
rook e8 and of course I'd rather be
white I want to play rookie 7 trading
rooks because again trading the rooks is
gonna even further accentuate the
strengths of the night over the bishop
you can imagine that much
is a direct line here just e to D 3 C 4
and I'm gonna take a lot of pawns but
white just calculated that oh I'm gonna
have a forced win and he played rook
takes g7 takes takes takes again it
looks like the King has a direct line
but you have to worry about the move f5
okay so after f5 pawn takes and then
stuff like a for King takes King
advances King takes that's going to give
the count lead can't apply so white was
counting on the move g4 thinking that
that's gonna win the game for him
because well either he's gonna freeze
the King side and then his King is gonna
just zoom ahead to the Queen side
winning or in the case of the exchange
is gonna get himself a protected
Passport
a huge asset in any endgame but
sometimes there are just unique et's to
every position that change it here's
mist of jumps and opportunity and an
opportunity that he never thought you'll
have so yeah of course so he takes takes
again looks completely winning for white
because there's an outside passport that
looks like it's gonna keep black really
busy also white is the option of playing
g4 locking the King said like I said
before and his King has a very super
easy access here notice that the King
has no chance to do anything but look at
what's missed off does what a beautiful
move g4 and first when I saw this move I
thought that this is a desperate attempt
that's gonna fail however it's a it's a
drawing move what is the point
obviously I'm threatening to take on h3
you can allow that if you take my king
is just gonna go advance advance advance
take it well that's gonna keep the White
King very busy on the King side so h4
now the black position looks like even
more dire than before not only is the
White King ready for his Express run to
the white squares all the way to the
pawns taking all of them at them Queenie
but the black king is now completely
tied down to defend against this
superfast express a h-bond but watch
what happens
see five very important kingi to king
eight seven again a beautiful waiting
move King D three King eight six all of
a sudden it occurred to white that the
wind is already not there and why
because well in the game he played in
the game he just played C 3 a 5 and
takes takes and they basically the game
is drawing they're just gonna play black
cannot win obviously he's just gonna
mark time against the h-bomb and white
can always mark time with e 2 and E 3
you might wonder wait a minute why
didn't he continued with his path as
expected King C 4 and the reason is that
in this position f5 now black wins this
is incredible you look at this position
you think yourself how can that be
possible
this just looks like a not a desperate
attempt at not losing all the pawns but
well now there are two possibilities one
of them is take after which efore this
is a motif that is really smart to etch
in your mind when the King is like this
cook at the C pawn and the e pawn that's
a super super position you just
paralyzed the pawn wants to Queen but
and that fridges the White King he can
never take the pawn he can never go here
and it can never go here that means if
you can out tempo him which of course is
a very easy task with this King I can
make a million moves with the King and
those two pawns are just too close to do
anything and then eventually you'll have
to either go here go here or take and
then my pawn is just gonna march easily
if you play C 3 trying to play a tempo
then I have the beautiful move a 5 just
maintaining the position so this
position is just lost for white he is in
zoobank his king is gonna run out of
moves is this understood anybody
Russians or anything did you want to say
something else oh yeah then a5 and I'm
just maintaining you take I take with
the a pawn we have the exact same
position just without the CNA pawns so
one would wonder what happened if I just
don't what if I play if I just say ok
let me just go back let me fix my
mistake well again too late just
for game over nothing you can do about
that now you really are in trouble takes
take skinny to and I can just play King
g6 that's it if you play h5 I take it if
you play if I take it and otherwise I'm
just gonna go King here and again the
pawns are just not far enough
I'm gonna just win one of those pawns
once they start pushing them it's gonna
be very easy to win them the game over
so at the last second I running not to
be confused with Aronian by the way
that's a veteran Russian player realize
that in this position after this his
journey to c4 need to stop right now and
just accept the draw one more movie
would have lost amazing to think that in
the starting position there was just
absolutely no reason to enter the
opponent but it was just an optical
illusion again even after the first move
rook here here had he played here Black
is just lost
I'm just intending to play route g7
which is unstoppable
then my knight is gonna just take pawns
and my king is just going to march this
way the bishop is just completely blind
totally lost a beautiful chance to be
the former world champion but missed her
next example again belongs to the same
category this time we're going to see
how to do it properly this is a very
very good technique by Leonid Stein I
know that you've guys seen him because
I've seen that burn Feingold had a
lecture about him or his ending maybe in
legends
he had that so in this position
obviously black is playing for a win and
he has a much better position and it's
his MO but he needs to be careful
because eight the pawns are doubled he
has two extra pawns but there are rook
pawns and double that makes life really
really hard it's like a two second
double whammy right and in addition to
that my rook is hitting one of them but
they're also tricks in the position as
you can see this is very weak and we can
also use our equal at some point to
advance
so the question is how to do it it looks
like many ways black is going to be
better of course regardless there is
just no way from black not to be better
but the question is how to make our task
the easiest and we already see that if
the route gets to age five this is going
to be super annoying because the rook is
going to be active is going to be
controlling the rank maybe it's going to
attack this pawn maybe attack this pawn
if there's a king then it doesn't let
him go up so very very difficult so for
first move h4 fantastic if he doesn't
play h4 he can play let's say it takes
takes and then you can play e5 that's
the idea but white might not take
immediately he might play King b3 all of
a sudden the two pieces are forked you
got a play here then I'm taking the pawn
with check you have to play here and
this is making life a lot harder just
unnecessarily harder all of a sudden
because here even if I take it and rook
takes and King moves this is a much
harder ending to win because I'm about
to take this guy and this guy maybe you
can win this one but it's becoming a
mess this is not the kind of ending here
you have to really calculate and I'll
tell you I don't want to go into this if
I'm black
if you edge a picture of this position
you will say yeah this is messy I'm
about to lose pawns and I can probably
win one of whites pawns but not both and
then I'm gonna be end up with maybe an
extra pawn and who knows what's gonna
happen instead what he did as we just
said he goes h4 G takes h4 what else I'm
threatening to take this pawn if I get
this one it's going to be just again
also I'm cutting the same thing on d4 so
when you took it then he talked rook to
d2 again the only attempt because now
after King d3 King d5 and I'm gonna
maintain my e pawn and that's just it's
all over so route D to e5 and we can
already see that this is going to win
after takes okay again black played a
beautiful little move
he understands that after pawn takes
rook takes maybe it's going to become
harder what does he do watch the next
move King e6 brilliant just a brilliant
move now white is in a pickle because
now the ponding is going to lose rook
takes rook takes pawn takes and the King
is going to march and take the pawn
that's what happened and alternatively
if you go away I'm gonna go rook takes
and then I'm gonna take the pawn then
I'm gonna be up three pawns plus with
very easy access to this guy and winning
easily so white had to play h5 trying to
save his pawn but it's too late
now takes takes takes a four again
trying to prevent King a five but he's
going this way takes oopsie yeah this is
the computer doing it again and after it
doesn't matter if you go to c5 you are
late by a mile that's obvious if you go
to here here here and you have to let go
immediately after let go if you go this
way I'm gonna go this way and just take
the pawn when the wanna me so beautiful
technique by Lil it's time and let's go
to position number three again same idea
and this position is pretty famous you
might have seen it before I don't know
but this is like it's a great example of
how somebody even at the level of the
player with the white pieces if get
especially carved a very well-known
Russian Grand Master was still active
today
he is playing against Garry Kasparov in
79 just when Gary was really starting to
show who he was who is really how strong
he was and in this position white is
definitely inferior everybody can see
that the black king is active has more
space all many of the pawns are on the
color of the bishop which is another
deficiency from my point of view and the
question is what to do in this position
here I can't blame him for playing
Bishop takes e5 because obviously the
bishop ending is very tough I mean it
looks like your Bishop is attacked if
you're just going to move the bishop
away let's say Bishop II won then
for who wants to play this kind of a
position right it's very very unpleasant
it looks like you're being pushed around
you will never be able to move the King
because if you go right I'll go left and
if you go left I'll go right
and penetrate and it's winning but if
you would have just kept a level head he
would have played Bishop III in this
position and there is really no win this
is not winning anymore
because after takes takes the King just
does not cross
you cannot go kini for because you
bishop please baby sinning and if you
move the bishop let's say if you go
Bishop here I'll play bishop here again
the King is not really crossing or I can
play King f3 maybe even to be really
annoying King f3 and again the King
doesn't cross so it would have been a
draw but instead he takes on c5 King
takes still you think yourself my
goodness how on earth are you going to
lose this I can protect all my pawns and
the problem is that you're going to get
yourself again into a position where I
trade all the pawns with the opposition
and I'm only easily so after if a3 King
before that's a variation worth
mentioning by the way if here King here
King here for a moment it seems like
Black has gotten nothing because white
is the opposition but I just have to
play this move the opposition has been
regained you can see that now once again
black owns the opposition and white is
doomed if you play b4 I'm just going to
take take and go here if you play a four
same thing I can even play b4 and again
if you go one way I'm gonna go another
way just take all your pawns and vice
versa so he tried God of our year [ __ ]
after here King d3 and watch out
Kasparov cashes in really beautiful King
before king c2 King a3 King b1 again
when we first look at the position you
think draw right the king is protecting
his stuff and white black has no past
forms no breaks no watch what he does
a5 white is exactly one move King here
still it looks very confusing how are
you going how on earth are you going to
do anything but this power of simply
place here threatening to take the pawns
so you must take and how to take back of
course with the king
you must leave yourself with the beep
one you must be able to trade that one
now if you go King beat you then before
let's say in the game you want King we
won again if King b2 doesn't solve it
because of before and a game the king is
gonna have to go back let's say King c2
King here King here
b3 just like in the game this is the
final position in the game as you will
see in a second after king b1 you and
King a3 forcing the poor King to go back
before the King ran out b3 and winning
why is it winning
well because whatever you do I'm just
gonna go and take your pawns after takes
takes King and all the pawns are ya
so as vestnik I've had to resign again
all based on one little decision that
seems so trivial getting rid of this
Bishop ending that was so bad but into a
lost and they okay next example again a
chance to beat a world champion
McKenna's is white against Boris Spassky
that was of course well before he was
world champion well before is even a
candidate so again in this position all
you have to do we have an extra pawn you
have to you have good winning chances
because again the King is a bit stock
there's a nice pin here the pawns cannot
really move so these are all good things
but he played Knight to d6 Island wait
one second alternatively King c4 check
King b3 again the pot on g4 cannot be
taken because 96 is gonna win the night
this time he's gotta go back now 96
rook has to go to e7
King here and the king is just gonna go
here and here and hunt the despawn not
very difficult right you can be the
world champion however in the game he
was in a rush and he played 96
Ruki 7 takes takes rook to see a of
course taking leads nowhere
so move d7 check King here activity
always leads to the best counter play it
looks like this pawn was lost but now we
have rugby for Chuck
so after takes here here here
h5 look here
simple and draw was agreed nothing the
King is just too far I'm just gonna go H
4 H 3 H 2 and supported with making sure
you can take this one but that's as good
as it gets
no Wayne anymore again very tempting to
go to the forcing pole endings of rock
endings in this case well you think that
just liquidating the material is going
to get you the point however now it's
amazing that they move like 96 is a
suspicious move because of rookie 7 the
correct move is to first get the King
closer to corral this pawn because you
will never be able to go this way so
after King c4 black is really stuck he
really has no no good moves in this
position now the idea of 96 is coming in
so you can't play h5 96 just wins
immediately the route can't go on your
if you go g6 I go Knight takes here so
just a real miserable position if you go
King here then h5 and the King just
keeps marching so they say check King
here now threatening rook takes f7 so
the rule can try to attack the pawn on
the C file now white plays this and now
after here King here
zhuge van mins beautiful women is this
clear any questions any comments okay
cool
now we're going to deal with some
blunders let's take a look at this
position this is a fantastic position I
really love it
I am sure that all of you already know
that a bishop and a rook pawn they don't
match on the last Condor queening square
is a draw regardless of the material in
other words if you pretend that those
two pawns are gone then of course it's a
draw
why is it a draw because Mikey can
always go King back and forth back and
forth
there is no way to take me out of the
corner without still meeting me ever how
many of you have known that before it's
I'm sure that most of you have some of
you okay if not then maybe I should
build the position doesn't matter if
it's white remember Black team at this
position is just a draw
why is it a draw because my King is
always going to go here let's say you
advance I go here check I go here here
here that's it you can never get me out
of the corner I'm always gonna have
moves if you try to be smart and play
check here and try to force me of
something let's you play this stomach
and alternatively no moves pawn advances
thumb it if you go back let's say then I
always I'm always gonna have a square
you always have to give me a square if
you don't give me a square I'll be still
man so when we understand that so yeah
if white could get rid of a ball of
pawns he's happy because as we saw it's
a draw very simple
however the question is how to do it
it's his move and he needs to be smart
about how he doesn't now you might say
what is the difference well the
difference is that again there's the
element of Zeus man Zhuge Zheng is when
you force your opponent to have to make
a move because that's the rules of chess
and any move he makes harms them any
move that he makes mix the things but
things worse here in this position white
plate clean g1 blunder of course after
King here this is immediately a draw why
first of all because a bishop
expand it look super attractive normally
we already know that that leads nowhere
and if black tries to force the King out
then I have this little beautiful move
and I'm like you want to take the pawn
it's still mate if not again I'm just
dancing with my King back and forth like
this like this like this like this dance
forever just nothing so you might wonder
why is this move a blunder and the
reason is King h3 now all of a sudden
white gets into judge van why let's take
a look in this position if you go key f1
but let's start with the easy one King
h1 Bishop c5 now without the pawn this
will be stalemate unfortunately you have
pawns and what are you going to do you
have to push them and now I take with my
pawn I don't have a root pawn anymore
now it's always winning
so after anything you do I'm just of
course my bishop is easily stopping the
bond and now I'm just winning because
check and mate I'm just coming here it's
gonna be made so there's no chance to
rush with a polygon so instead
we're gonna play King f1 but now king h2
again now we may need to chase the white
thing away from the corner imagine
losing a position like this I would have
been in tears so and again it's just
over nothing you can do about it because
now let's say after here I just take I
just take and if you go here I'm just
gonna go eventually I just get to this
position now I don't even care if I have
the bishop or not you can do whatever
you want you can just you can have my
dish up here and my pawn just marches in
Queenie so even the symbols of positions
have so much venom in them to think that
this position white is going to lose you
have to be really clumsy because you
shouldn't but the point here was that
white just didn't realize that one of
two things can happen he is going to be
kicked out of the corner or is going to
be put in zoogs done in the corner where
he has to push his born and when it's
being captured then there's no roof on
when the wind is just a regular point of
course it's winning easily because I can
always force the king out of the Queen
Square any questions or comment
everybody understand
let's see another set blunder especially
if I'll find it and this blunder is made
by no other than Louie Paulson Louis
Paulson was the best player in Europe
when Morphy was the best player in the
US they even played the match and more
free kill them but nonetheless he is one
of the best players of all time India in
Europe at least at the back in the 19th
century here he has a winning position
again based on the idea that we saw
before but he manages to be very clumsy
about it and he doesn't win in the game
he plays the move King c4 now again it
looks like Aviv what are you showing us
the guy has an extra bishop and there's
no way to trade the pawns so the King
can even get to the corner so of course
we're just gonna push him away from the
pawn and win the game well in theory it
sounds beautiful
but in practice it's it's harder of
course what he should have played was
king d4
just to be very very cautious about
things and the moment that black pushes
his porn let's say here then we're gonna
play a six not let the King notice that
the king is getting absolutely no
approval to go to the corner cannot let
him I'm not letting him cross that is
the important thing and now after this
here and the King doesn't get anything
if you play before I take it and
eventually what's going to happen is
that they're going to push the King away
and Mikey is gonna go all the way to b7
then I move the bishop then I Queen my
pawn with no effort is that clear is
that part clear yeah so what to do
instead after whoopsie after king d4 we
can try King c6 and now simply Bishop to
b6 now the beautiful thing is I am just
not letting you play the pit of the be
pond or get to the corner soon you will
see why moving the be pond also leads to
a draw in many positions now you have a
problem if you're gonna go away I'm just
going to corral you and I'm gonna get
this pawn if you run this way like for
example let's say King here King here
King here came here King here in here in
here here you gotta love to me take your
pawn and my pawn just marched us in I'm
gonna become I'm gonna have a queen and
winning so huge problem so you might
wonder what is the difference between
one move or another and he could have
also played king c5 oops sorry king c5
and here black again has a draw but he
has to be accurate about it he cannot
play any King move because I'm just
gonna get to b6 and then I'm gonna win
this pawn once I want this pawn it's
over if you play b5 it's also not enough
because I go a6 and I push your king but
if you play b6 then it's a draw this
position is a draw and again you have to
know those positions look what happened
in the game that's actually the best
example
the point is b5
that's draw because if you take their
King be seven remember the rook pawn
rule rook pawn and the bishop that
doesn't hit the Queenie square you
cannot win it's a stalemate and of
course the other option is if you play
pawn takes a pass on then again King to
be seven this is a position that is a
must to know I always going to play King
here King here if you try to take it
away from me
stalemate so let's say here here let's
you try to do this stalemate if you went
here and after king c6 stomach once more
also yeah these positions are very
important to remember because they are
there are many positions like this for
example let me show you another one
that's another one monitors position
that does not win why doesn't it win
because again you cannot prevent me from
playing King ace king a 8 B 7 if you go
here I'll go here the knight can't move
because I'll take the pawn the pawn
can't move because I'll take it and the
King can never support it let's say you
play some move wait I go to the corner
if you try to take stuff away from me
immediately stomach so be very very
careful about how to push the pond I've
seen this happen in games but somebody's
extra night especially in blitz games
you have an extra night in the pawn you
just push the pawn thinking what's the
difference let's keep the King busy but
you have to give the King room if the
pawn was on a 6 then it's an easy win a
very easy win because I'm just going to
come with my key to here and at the
right time we're going to play check and
if you go out my pond will Queen if you
go in my knight will make you the
difference is that this King is going to
be like here and then my knight will
just make you so yeah clear or any
questions I think this one yeah once
again same topic and let's see if one of
you well actually is solving it there's
gonna be it's gonna take too much time
so I'm just going to look at it and
explain it here it's obvious that white
is to make a bishop move because if I'm
gonna go King here I'm gonna take you
pawn so you have to think yourself
should you move the bishop it looks like
you can make many many bishop moves all
the bishop moves seemed like that
possible here here here here here here
here but only one of them wins and it's
really tricky if you haven't seen it
before well I'm gonna play the move and
you will see as the game progresses why
it's like that Bishop d7 the only move
to win now you might say what's the
difference between this move and every
other move let's see King III again a
must
my king just now I have a very simple
plan if you come to the point I'm gonna
March it if you go King f3 I'm just
gonna start marching with my king very
quickly and I'm gonna get you into a
zeus time so King III h4 now if King at
for King d4 is immediately a zigzag what
this is what I was talking about now you
have to go backwards you have no access
points next to my pawn you have to go
back my pond just Queens that's too easy
so King efore and now h5 I'm allowed to
go at 6
so King e58 6 forced to go King here and
now Bishop e8 the key move of the
position the bishop is far away where
it's not being attacked but good enough
to where is controlling this
all-important diagonal and now that's it
if you could say pass you'll be in good
shape however in chess there's no pass
you have to make a move and you're in
zoogs run any move you make I'm going to
play eight seven and the pawn just
marches in so Bishop d7 the only move
where the King cannot attack it on the
way to where he is in gain a temple and
on the other hand where it's close
enough you can still occupy this very
short h5e a diagonal you have to prevent
the king from going to those squares yes
I don't think so I don't think so
because I'll have to look at it because
I let's try to build it actually and
answer it promptly so we are pretending
that the king is here but not here and
of course with white unit so let's
pretend that we go Bishop d7 for example
and I have a feeling that this is
already not good because King here now I
just want to run to the corner so after
here here and I don't have to worry
about this King before that with Zhuge
Liang me so now if you go let's say if
you push the pot I'm just attacking you
and then I'm running to the corner and
if you try to be here then I'm already
know you have to you must use the key as
a shelter as one of those walls that
prevent the key from grout running to
the corner and or taking you up on so
when we go and I have three more things
to show you or maybe four do we have
time mm-hmm okay maybe I'll skip one
okay we'll talk a little bit about the
idea of rook versus night because rook
versus night generally speaking is a
draw for example let's use this example
and in this position it's white to move
it looks like he almost maximize his
potential
however he cannot win so check King -
not King c1 because King b3 that's
terrible obviously but King c1 King here
now if you make a queen you get made it
so you have to make a knight but that's
good enough
that's simply good enough after King
here 93 that is already a draw you
cannot create a medic position and a
very important principle the king and
the knight are together the ideas for
the King in this night - you cannot
separate them once they're separated
it's automatically a win as you will see
from the following example so this is
just a very simple draw after here
I have to play 91 not 95 if I go 95
that's already over excuse me the king
of the lights are separated now it's
over I will win the night for sure
there's just no question about it a
knight can never make it back between
the domination of the rook overnight and
all kinds of pins and checks you always
lose the night that's that's easy so but
in this position after rook after night
b1 then it's a draw the King cannot come
closer to create a mating situation even
though you managed to cut my king as
deep as you could on the last ring there
is no victory if this rook was a queen
but then it's an easy win but of course
because then you can also play on the
diagonals and already you're threatening
mate here something that you wouldn't be
threatening right if it's white if it's
white to move it it's a queen it's mate
on the move so yeah okay so this was an
easy example and the next one is really
really nice
this is a beautiful combination take a
look at this one so he before again you
have no time to take the beep on because
I will just go a to and then you it'll
be a drop quickly so King to be for a 2
he to be 3 almost the same position is
before only black has the extra beep on
and watch what difference it makes night
King here and now what to do before the
only move any Knight move is going to
lose right so before not the game
becomes more exciting King takes Knight
C to G c3 again any position that's very
important to remember it looks like now
the knight has to be safe because we're
running with it but it's too late
if you play another move let's say if
you play 981 all I have to do is just go
like rook g2 and the night is gone if
you go King here its mate if you move
the knight here oh here I'm just gonna
take it so this is again a position
that's worth memorizing so 93 let's say
it's the same thing on either a three by
the way if not a three I should mention
that as well just King here threatening
mate and the night immediately over so
93 now you have two winning moves
actually you can play King b3 I play
root page for it doesn't really matter
both of them women let me just
demonstrate how after King V 395 rue
Cage poured the night is just there's no
way once they're separated it's just
over King here roof d4 that's it if
Knight b6 check if it's if here did you
just go rook here tonight will always be
lost so yeah even with the extra pawn it
plays a great part in the beginning
however this position is just lost so
rue cage for let's check the moves 91
check King d2 Knight bTW it looks like
it's good but after here here here zooks
van rook a for is mate
if the knight moves and of course if you
go here I'm not gonna take the knight
thank you very much but I'm just gonna
make some move with a rock let's say you
work here now yeah
and over threatening rookie a rookie
eight and it just went alternatively
let's look at other moves here Chuck and
here
always tricks either i4q or either I
skew you or now it's a combination of a
mate and night and once the night and
the king is separated it's over
okay how much time do I help actually
maybe I'll manage to do both so first
we'll see this composition no not this
one just promote seen already this one
this I was really impressed by because
in this position white is up a bishop
this is kind of a acute composition wipe
this up a bishop but it's obvious that
the g2 pawn is just too valuable all I
want to do is just move my bishop and
I'm just gonna Queen my pawn what you do
against that so these six Jack again and
move that looks really crazy because you
think why am I giving this pawn away and
we check Nola's well there's a reason
behind it and you will see it in a
second everything to get to the proper
position that we learned before so if
instead we play Bishop c5 then after
Bishop h2 you must push the f1 let's say
here doesn't matter
in both cases I'm gonna take now here
because I was threatening to play Bishop
g3 check and f2 cleaning my pawns
submission peer and now simply Bishop
before winning beautifully because I
want to go Bishop here and Bishop here
painting your Bishop and then the pond
is gonna quit just beautiful and watch
it's not over yet here here threatening
Bishop h4 Bishop check b8 Kiev - the
only move because any other move let's
say you go
d6 I'm gonna go Bishop h4 pinning your
bishop and the pawn is gonna create our
Queen immediately action in this
specific position so King f2 and now
another sacrifice from the other side
and after he takes pawn Queens the queen
is just too strong obviously and wins
so you're still wondering why these six
take a look
this extract you gotta take it otherwise
I'm gonna take it takes and now sack no
I took away the h2 square you better
take me now see five check you
sacrificing everything on the queenside
you gotta take that what else to play
Bishop f1 now of course I'm 32 take the
pawn and immediately make a draw so
takes takes attacking the bishop bishop
page to f3 again a beautiful little move
just like we saw before
now I'm threatening to take the pawn if
you take me I go King f2 and I just wind
up on so you must try to go you must try
to go here but then we already know that
after here or f4 doesn't matter we have
a drawn position after the King starts
advancing I'm just gonna pitch my pawn
take it and then King to the corner we
know that you can never ever get me out
of here I'm always gonna have King h1
King G - just like we saw before
understood now as a finale I'm gonna
show you something really cute I might
have shown it before somewhere but I'm
not positive in any way in any event
this is something you can see again and
stay a lot like you like the same this
is very cute end game when you see this
position white is up a whole rock but
the beep one is about to become a queen
and it looks unstoppable if I manage to
make a queen of course is just over so
in a series of forced move we're gonna
have a very cute position and pay
attention to what happened rook B for
now it is black that looks really really
in trouble because I'm about to just
take your beep on and you cannot Queen
it so it looks really really bad so what
does he do rook h4 so now the rook is
pinning the rook that's attacking the
pawn now white is in trouble because
black is threatening be one Queen so
white plays c4 again disrupting the
connection between the two rooks once
again he is threatening to take the pawn
on b2 and he's going to be up at least
points in attending even if he appalling
enemy even if he's losing that Brook so
proof takes and now Bishop to b5 now we
have a funny kind of funny play the rook
is pinning this rook but the bishop is
pinning the rook that spinning the rock
so what does he do he plays Bishop d7
he's pinning that Bishop why because if
he makes a queen then he's gonna lose
his rook and then rook takes Queen not
good so the bishop is on d7 now the
bishop is pinning the bishop the
spinning the rock the spinning the rock
so what do we have to do rook da pinning
the bishop and we have a multiple pin
the rock pins the bishop that pins the
bishop that pins the rock the pins of
rock now of course black is in trouble
cause he have no ears no more pieces to
do anything so he can try to play Queen
unfortunately for him after it takes
here takes he just loses he is down two
rooks are probably is gonna lose his
Queen I'm guessing after king bee to
rugby rugby for and what just a
beautiful little dessert for finish
thank you very much for attending my
lecture